I guess a Tom Hanks plays Sully who at
this point looks enough like Sully for
me to say okay they make an uncharted
movie I want Tom Hanks to play Sully I
mean why not totally fine with it Sully
so Sully is the true story of the pilot
who landed the airliner in the Hudson
River like I think it was in 2009 you
guys remember that his plane was gonna
crash pilot lands it in the Hudson River
everyone on board lives everyone's like
always a hero is a hero is a hero then
some people were like wilt is a hero did
he endanger people's lives by landing it
in the Hudson River maybe he could have
made it to the airport maybe he was high
I heard someone ask if he was high was
weird so this is a true story of the
pilot who was a mixed that shitstorm Tom
Hanks plays the pilot Sully Clint
Eastwood directs and here we go
what I liked about this movie is easy
enough to spot so I'm just gonna say
right off the bat Tom Hanks oh my gosh
the dude is one of the greatest actors
living today possibly one of the Great's
of all time
all right to me he's one of the Great's
of all time so whatever I'll fight
anybody who says otherwise he just gives
it 150% every time granted at this point
is career you know what you're getting
when he plays a role like this he's
gonna be a dude who's very focused on
point he's very professional and he
always kind of talks like this you know
I'm gonna be judged on 208 seconds that
is not an impersonation it's just a
demonstration of how he talks but it's
what you're in for you know it's what
you get in this movie who else is
awesome though Aaron Eckhart it's great
this movie too is the copilot and you
totally buy ham and Tom Hanks is pilot
and co-pilot what this is is a really
personal story of a guy who is going
through the strain that this pilot went
through me you would think it's just
black and white you would think all
right this plane is gonna crash this guy
lands it in the Hudson River everyone
lives hooray hit him that along the
dudes if we can get him back to flying
and saving more lives but it's not
really like that from an insurance
perspective there has to be scrutiny and
they have to look into [ __ ] and have to
be like what up hmm maybe maybe not
maybe you save lives maybe you were a
dick and maybe you endangered lives
which if I were running a company I
would want investigation to just it's it
kind of sucks to see there is fair and
evidence will speak for itself but the
dude literally did the impossible that
everyone on this flight lived and so you
just want to do
this guy on your shoulders and say free
drinks for the rest of your [ __ ] life
even at a point you start questioning I
saw this all go down on the news already
had my preconceived notions in my head
this movie actually made me go with hmm
maybe maybe he did make the wrong choice
I don't know I just they're bringing up
some good points maybe that's part of
the effectiveness of the movie so in
that I did like how it wasn't just a
wash it wasn't just like alright this
side of the story and the other slide is
not there it's it's good to see both
sides of it it's good to see that people
are just human beings doing their jobs
doing their human being jobs doesn't
change the fact that Sully is betrayed
as the American here this dude is like
so awesome I hope I grow up to be him I
won't I'm Way too eccentric to be as
cool collected and respected in life
what I am Sully's age is just the way
it's going to go doesn't change the fact
that I look up to dudes like that in the
end Sully is a very well acted well
directed personal look at a very intense
situation that someone did were at first
was like hero and then it's like oh yeah
insurance and companies and yeah money
hundred fifty five people lived doesn't
matter the Blaine sang it is a long haul
kind of movie so I almost feel like you
should be interested in the subject
matter before you go into it but if you
remember this situation as it happened
makes it a hundred times more
interesting I had a good time with Sully
I will say Sully is a good time no
alcohol required bye guys so Sully have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite Clint Eastwood
directed movie of all time whatever it
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]